taste buddies
no press fleshers that means you're no
press for life body and soul
we got road dates coming up not together
separately
but you know look
hopefully they're on separate weekends
and you can see both of us
and if we're on the same weekend in your
town you're gonna have to make a choice
i don't know what to tell you
but i'll be at helium
comedy club in buffalo uh january 27th
28th 29th i'm going to be at bananas in
new jersey
uh the 4th and 5th of february i'm going
to be at the punch line in philadelphia
march 10th 11th and 12th and i'm going
to be
at
uh in austin texas at the creek and cave
uh the 20th and 21st of may and there's
some other dates and things that are
popping up that i'm not allowed to
announce yet but will be coming soon
to a city near you
guys just come see me i'm in a bad way
you know i mean you can hear it i can't
i can't remember my website name
uh i'll see you out there
jodarossainfo.com for all tickets uh
links and and show info and all that
good stuff will be there what's up guys
it's a new year i'm on the road it's
been a while please come out and see me
everything on
savilecanocomedy.com as far as tickets
go i'm gonna be in san diego i'm gonna
be in los angeles uh burlington vermont
uh foxwoods and then uh further into
february detroit we have two shows on
february 11th pittsburgh two shows on
february 12th albany two shows on
february 18th tysons virginia were there
on the 19th two shows in madison on
february 26th two shows at the vic in
chicago i'm so excited about that on
february 27th right now chrissy d and i
will also be at the ryman auditorium in
nashville on march 11th i am going to be
adding dates and cities all the time all
on salvolcanocomedy.com i've been having
a blast on the road i'm excited to come
see you guys go to the website check me
out i'll see you soon
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds hi sally hey babes what's
up nothing much how are you i'm good
nothing i love that you're wearing a
different
yeah different skulls that i did last
week yeah it's cold out there again i
like different attacks that's fun
i like that you looked in your bag and
you're like let me just look in the
closet he's like three knit hats with
you i'm i'm at that level of stress and
depressed right now
what's that called when you have the
standard wardrobe where you don't have
to pick like einstein did it oh yeah
like steve jobs yeah yeah i did or
whatever i should do that i'm gonna went
on the road i used to just take a v a
black v-neck yeah and not think of it
anymore i forget what it's called i
think ashton kutcher does it i've been
trying to do that uh lately with like
three colors of t-shirts and pants he
will the same thing every day i get it
and i don't get it
he won't know
albert einstein uh
for efficiency often wore the same
ensemble every day no socks a gray suit
and his leather levi's
menlo
or a leather jacket over a suit
particularly noteworthy because he
bought it around the time he was
becoming an american citizen in the
mid-1930s
speaking of speaking to einstein oh my
god
he i mean he's crazy he must have
smelled yeah
no speaking of yeah
[Laughter]
i'm sure you know he wants no he had
like several gray suits is what they're
saying i thought he did too like don't
get me wrong i bought a three pack of
those these yeah yeah wearing the same
thing every night yeah you wear the same
jacket every day but that's it he
doesn't look like he smells good the uh
he does not
there's a great uh take advice from him
if i saw him on the street
i i'd actually i'd probably mock him on
his back
you see that guy do you ever see that
i've been re-watching kids in the hall
yeah because they just added them to
prime the sketch where david foley is
dave foley's painting he's got paint all
over him there's paint everywhere in the
driveway
and uh kevin mcdonald walks up off
camera and you just hear his voice and
he goes uh he goes what are you doing
some painting and he's like yeah
einstein i'm doing some painting what
tipped you off einstein what made you
realize einstein that i'm painting and
then it cuts again mcdonald's and he's
einstein
and he makes this crate he goes like
this and he turns around and as he's
walking away he's going
you're the genius walk away
he's the painter you're the genius
shout out kids in the hall shout out
canada yeah shout out
you know they got a new
new
kids in the hall coming out on amazon
prime with the original cast yeah oh my
god joy yeah i didn't know that i went
to go see them when i first started
doing sketch and stand up with the guys
we'll go see them in 2003. i saw them at
like city city uh town hall i think
and they did this whole thing i've seen
them multiple times and we wait we
waited around back yeah well we waited
on the side door when they were gonna
come out
with a bunch of other people and when
they came out a little bit after there
was a van waiting to take them away and
i had just performed my very first
improv show on it was march 4th 2000 was
when i
performed so it was right actually not
two down three two thousand and uh we
had made
like uh we call those like programs for
the people in the audience that came to
the show
and so we had programs on us and were
like we want to do what they are doing
it was like 20. and so they they came
out and we were like oh and everyone's
like taking pictures and looking and
they're like thank you they maybe
started wanting to go in the van and
we're like
you know who everybody whatever one of
them i'm like oh
we're we're in a county troop we're in
the comment show and i can't on the the
the program and he takes it and like
he's like thank you thank you thank you
and then they go in the car and they'll
get in the van they close the van but
you see them still and then everyone's
like calling and yelling and they're
waving everything and i'm like
and he goes this is you this is you
what's his name um
uh kevin uh mcdonald yeah i think kevin
i think no not kevin mcdonald and i go
yeah this is us this is us he goes okay
okay and they drove away and in our like
you know green like we were like oh my
god they know about us now they have the
pamphlet they have to plan for our
contact information is on that pamphlet
what odds are why would we say like kind
of medium to high that they're going to
call us and we'll be like performing
with them or something like that
we thought that you know like maybe
they'll like it maybe they'll go to the
you know see what we do like us and who
knows
maybe we'll get a call
maybe they'll maybe they'll uh you know
contact us did i ever tell you did i
ever tell my kids a long story on the
show i don't know no
i saw them at the nokia center okay
uh and my friend bjorn was tour managing
for them so he called me and he goes do
you want to come to kids at home you
have a friend named bjorn yeah yeah he
lives in england now but anyway he goes
you want to come to the nokia center see
kids in the hall i'll get you free
tickets and then with a plus one and
then you can come hang with us backstage
for the party after and i was like are
you kidding party yeah they had a
backstage party at in the
the fancy green room at the nokia center
okay
with like 20 people okay yeah i know
that and i went
and i was a comic i was pretty new maybe
five years in okay
um
and we went and me and my buddy jim
who's very handsome fellow uh we went
went backstage we were hanging out
backstage
getting blasted on free drinks picture
jim
he looks like a young paul newman
uh he's closed yeah very good looking
kid and uh and he was in his prime door
at this period right so we go backstage
my friend jane bourdain cool time yeah
yeah my friend jane borden was back
there she used to work for a friend
named jane yeah
she worked for uh was it time out in new
york or village voice one of those
magazines anyway
she wanted to she wanted she was there
covering the event and she said do you
want to interview scott thompson
for me and i was like are you kidding so
i sat with scott thompson we hit it off
big time
and he took a liking to my friend who
unfortunately is straight bjorn i don't
know jane jim jim i think somebody the
the the paul newman looking forward they
said jane i don't know why no my friend
jane worked a timeout in new york asked
me to interview too much
anyway here's the point this is the
story after that party ends dave foley
scott thompson
and kevin mcdonald
want to go to a bar it wasn't yeah me
and jim are already hanging out with
kevin and mcdonald's
mcdonald's curly black hat yeah that's
who it was yeah yeah yeah that is who it
was they go do you guys know a bar i go
i know a great bar it's called smith's
bar it's right in we're right in the
neighborhood the one on the corner yeah
we go to it we're drinking with them
i've had some nights today uh yeah me
too we're sitting at a table me and my
friend jim and scott thompson scott
thompson at one point says to me like
you know you're when he's in the
bathroom your friend jim's cute whatever
right and i go yeah yeah you know what
are you gonna do
i go to the bar to order i'm gonna do
yeah i order i go to the bar to order us
a round of drinks right
i have not spoken to kevin mcdonald of
this night at all other than maybe
saying oh we're going to this whatever
yeah i'm standing at the bar waiting to
get a round of drinks i am shit-faced
and elated that i'm hanging out with
kids in the hall
i feel a presence come up behind me
it's got it's it's it's kevin mcdonald i
don't know it's him yet i just know
somebody's behind me and how i tell it's
him is i feel this presence lean into my
ear and say
you know scott's trying to fret
so great that's so great it's the
greatest it was like this is the and
that's all he said to me and i just
laughed i was like i think i think so
right
and that was it and then i just walked
away and then we hung out with scott
thompson and then like i sort of kept
like loose touch for a little while with
scott thompson after that but now we
have the same manager you exchange info
we did
i haven't
i never really spoke to him again we
kind of texted once or twice that was it
but then we now have the same manager
and i wanted to try to become friends
with scott thompson especially he goes
he just released a cd or an album
of his band it was him and that guy paul
bellini that was on the show they had a
band together they just the name is
escaping me at the moment but they just
literally like a week ago released
a compilation of their old demos that
they recorded when they were what type
of music is is there anything like uh it
sounded exactly it's anything like
linguine sunsets can i tell you
something
sauce or windfall i'll tell you
something
can i tell you something
i'm not kidding son says it's casey's i
am not kidding can i tell you something
when q texted me that he was listening
to the salsa info album and other people
messaging thank you
i said the cue i go
i go number one i was on so much acid
when we recorded that i don't remember
recording it
number two
i go that was the polished versions of
the songs i go the original versions of
all those songs were all done with casio
keyboards and fortr and a four track i
go they are completely bugged out and
like whatever and i go those are the
ones i really want to release
i listen to scott thompson's band i'm
sitting there going
this sounds no it would have been
matches made in heaven like you could
open for them i don't think they play
anymore what is the salsa windfall did
you just come into a lot of salsa
that was the we were eating nachos when
we were really we were really stoned
recording our first demo oh and we're
choosing right now we're i know we're
eating nachos that we made ourselves me
and my buddy paul who's the other guy
and uh he said paul chell and he said uh
what do you want to name the band and i
was like i don't know what he wanted to
name it he's like it should be something
about salsa and i was like okay he goes
salsa windfall that's a good idea and i
didn't know what that i didn't know at
the time
i thought he was making a fart joke
okay and he i was like oh that's a funny
fart joke and he's a windfall means like
we like inherited a lot of salsa and i
was like okay
that's great anyway
shout out to scott thompson i am
thrilled that they are gonna do i would
love to see what their minds come up
with now they just released a few set
photos oh i'm psyched and those guys
have to be late 50s 60s right maybe late
50s i think
i think they're all about 60 now yeah
60. which gives me like life because i
love to see that people are still doing
comedy like a group like that there's
paul ballen still doing comedy at that
age
yeah i think they're i think they're
about 60.
um it won't tell you on i don't think it
tells you on here pimp
oh it does he's born in 63. i like wiki
because ricky will just give you the the
yeah you have to do the math yeah 63 is
not yet 60. he's 50
58 59.
uh
yeah 59 yeah so they're they're right
there
you know but god bless they're all still
working they're all still doing what
what network is it on
it's gonna be on amazon prime that's why
amazon prime just picked just just
released all all five seasons of the
original show
so you can watch them all now
i know i've been tearing through i know
what i might be doing later i know what
i'm doing dude i'm getting a little duck
from the chinese place and i'm gonna eat
it with some leftover mash that i have
and a nice salad i'm gonna watch some
kids in the hall yeah in my head i just
pictured like a little like a baby duck
by the way he said a little duck i got
an audio return
from q okay from last episode all right
of us laughing let's see what he says
ready
yeah oh it's only four seconds maybe
it's just him laughing
i'm listening
oh i'm listening
there you go i'm listening i'm listening
all right
all right we got to get to the battle
but what's this yeah so i got you a
little something for the chris chris
um
it it i saw it like i said i mentioned
it last step i saw it and i thought of
you uh i i will leave it at that
i will let you have your full reaction
all i will say is
and i don't want to give anything away
but i think i know the answer all right
so you go ahead and just do it and
you open that up and you tell me what
you think
don't worry about that okay
it looks like some sort of collectible
something or other looks like a sign
possibly
don't pick it up from the glass joe i
didn't turn it turn it to the way that
you could read it i could i would leave
all that the way where it is yeah
you're upside down babe you're upside
down
[Laughter]
does it say cocktails and dreams yes
do you know the reference no is that
from cocktail
it's their sign it's the name of their
bar
come on young flamingon
did not get that reference that was the
whole thing it was like are you gonna
get this revenge you don't remember the
movie i saw the hotels and dreams babes
you just opened the bar i know no no i
get why you would buy me a sign that's
it
listen i get why you would buy me a sign
that says cocktails and dreams my
assumption was it was from the movie
cocktail the reason i don't remember is
because i only saw cocktail once as a
young boy and i remember being very
disappointed at how serious and dark the
film got and that it wasn't just about
two guys flipping drinks to some content
i thought it was going to be like there
was a contest in vegas
with a bottle of scotch
brandy at the end yeah but also you got
elizabeth chewing her prime in that babe
but you got to plug it in
i can't you can't how do you get
would resonate with you the way it
resonated with me i liked it so much i
bought one for myself
i swear to god now do you realize and my
dad do you realize this is the same my
dad loves it we have usually the vhs
cassette in the house my dad has a
little bar in his house now yeah not
that he even drinks but he's so proud
that he has like it's so cool he has a
bar and everything he's wanted one his
whole life and so i got us i got one for
him for you and for me and i thought
like i could
literally give the cocktail speech right
now off memory
i thought that you would like because
that's that's as eighties as i mean that
is the quintessential i don't wanna
always sell the gift anyone forget it
listen to me it's a neon i love the gift
i can't wait to hang it in the bar yeah
just be careful because it might be
delicate i know it's kind of ripple
just put it in my own home i know
pimp can you give us a plug
and we'll see this thing lit up
oh look at that
you could it'll fit very nicely in your
apartment too with the style of your
opponent but yeah it was it was a nod to
you're a bar owner now man and that is
the quintessential bar sign i love it
that's where my head was at thank you
for buying it for me and i feel now's a
good time as any i need help
do you know of any meetings i could
start
not to mock sorry i'm not trying to mock
anybody that doesn't need help i'm just
making a
joke because of the timing it's more of
a timing job i understand you haven't
explained to me than an a.a joke yeah uh
all right i can't i believe you didn't
get the reference out of the gate though
buddy that was a bit of a that was a bit
of a deflation you said you get the
reference and i went is it from cocktail
i think you said no first and then said
is from okay but i got it pretty goddamn
quick yeah i mean i understand when you
looked at it you understand that you
did it for what it was at face value
even you were like cocktails and the
fact that something says cocktails and
dreams and lights up neon that was all i
needed right
you know now
the fact that i'm also in the brian
brown fan club
that helps
brian brown yeah that's the guy's name
that was the gut slits his throat
his name was brian brown yes wait a
minute everybody thinks it's michael
caine it's not it's brian brown wait you
didn't know the reference and you're
telling me what his name is well you're
gonna talk to me like i never saw the
movie fx or fx2 that also starred brian
brown that's his real name
yeah what yeah oh i didn't know that was
his real name yeah
let's see what he's up to lately he's
around i think he was in uh you know
what he's in he plays the uh
insurance the guy they need to ensure in
along came polly that's like i'm gonna
jump off the building mate yeah that's
the cocktail guy
this is a great gift sally thank you i'm
in touch you're welcome
and i would hug you if i wasn't going to
hug you already in three minutes when we
start god bless it god bless it let's
see what brian brown's up to you yeah
i'll i'll do that for you you can just
shove that over to the side let's talk
about lucy folks lucy nicotine is a
company founded by caltech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner nicotine alternative finally
tobacco alternatives that don't suck
okay
researched and developed for three years
to be made for people not patients lucy
has created a nicotine gum with four
milligrams of nicotine that come in
three flavors winter green cinnamon and
pomegranate fancy fans lucy has a
lozenge with four milligrams of nicotine
and cherry ice flavor each and every
flavor actually tastes great it's
convenient it's discreet products can be
enjoyed anywhere on flights or at work
on the go in the gym
i actually was sent a bunch of lucy now
i used to be a smoker uh i smoked for uh
10 years quit for six smoked again for
three and i've been off it for six so
right now i don't need to quit otherwise
i would have used lucy to try for sure
um
i got a package and i just gave the
package to my best friend donato who
have knowns into her children i want him
to quit smoking he told me it was a new
year's resolution he smokes like two
packs a day he came over the other day
and i gave him all my gums and lozenges
he was thrilled i will check back in
with you guys on the next ad seriously
to let you know how it's going anyway
it's 2022 get rid of your cigarettes
unplug your vape throw out your dip and
get some lucy nicotine gum or lozenges
it's the real deal a subscription to
lucy comes directly to your door each
month it's so simple you don't have to
leave your house because lucy has
delivery down for our taste buds
listeners go to lucy.co.com.co
and use promo code tastebuds to get 20
off all the products on your first order
including the gum or the lozenges so
this is the cleaner alternative i will
check back in with you guys and let you
know how his lucy journey is going but
he was excited nonetheless to get it
it's really cool it comes in these
little like discs with all the different
flavors i like the branding uh i'll let
you know how that goes that's lucy.co
and use promo code tastebuds at checkout
also i have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical lucy.co be sure to
use that promo code tastebuds
kids i want to talk to you about
athletic greens uh they are a new
sponsor to the show and i am thrilled
about that because i've been using them
for at least two years now um i love
athletic greens i can't say that about
every single thing we talk about but
this is something i've used for two
years um
it comes it's really cool it comes in
this i have it in a canister that has
like a wooden top on it a scooper and i
keep it in the fridge and it's so easy
they give you this uh their own like
water bottle it's like a water bottle
and every morning it's my first thing i
do in the morning i replace my
multivitamin with it i take a scoop i
put up a bunch of filtered water in
there i shake it up and i either drink
it right there on the spot or i actually
sip it a little bit over the course of
like an hour or two because it
suppresses my appetite that's not
something they're claiming i'm just
telling you that's how it happens for me
or i just take it on the go i run out i
throw in my backpack and i know that i
have something to drink every day i was
hesitant at first because i used to try
to juice as much as i can especially
greens and i hated the taste this is
just me talking um athletic greens
actually i actually like the taste it
does not taste like the earth it doesn't
taste like sod uh actually it just
tastes like this really kind of
kind of tropical taste i don't know how
to explain it but i really really do
love the taste um it's how i start every
morning i replace my vitamins with it so
i like it i i just give it a try it's
it's all your vitamins in one it
promotes good gut health it gives me
energy those are all the reasons i like
doing it um taking it
that's a lifestyle friendly so whether
you eat keto paleo vegan dairy-free or
gluten-free uh that's important i didn't
even know that it's good for all of that
it contains less than a gram of sugar uh
it costs less than three dollars a day
if you're investing in your health it's
cheaper than a cold brew habit or
getting fresh pressed juice
athletic greens has over 7 000 five-star
reviews and it's recommended even by
professional athletes i think it's great
right now guys it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into the flu season and the cold
season it's just one scoop in a cup of
water every day and that's really it no
need for a million different pills
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d
and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
taste buds again that is
athleticgreens.com
taste buds to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
can we go to brian brown's wiki babe
yeah go to the top though let's see what
his latest effort is shout out a movie
called darby and jones 2022 is that tv
mini series he was in a mini series last
year he was in a series before year
before that year before that
i mean he is literally full-on with us
he's live and active like yogurt
all right
let's
let's go to uh can you just google him
so i can see what he looks like these
days
oh there it is yeah he's still very much
oh you're right that is him yeah he was
in that movie yeah wow i didn't know his
name was in that movie he's the other
guy no no in uh in polly yeah i was like
oh i see it now
yeah yeah
yeah everybody you know he used to get i
think people always thought it was
michael caine in cocktail
no it's brian brown well brian brown
yeah
anyway
good stuff it's weird yeah shout out to
brian what is this from
what cocktails i mean starring brian
brown
i love the gift i love it i love it i
love it you love it i don't think that
you believe that i love it i do i just
thought it was odd that you could name
the guy in the movie but didn't realize
that that was the reference but i mean
in a good way i'm an enigma it's a fun
thing you are you're in a [ __ ] anyway
all right
all right we're doing morning versus
evening
uh we will get back to a food battle
next week uh but we were we came up with
these and these have been sitting in the
docket for a long time and we thought
they were real this one is gonna this
one is anybody's game
this one is anybody's game evening's
gonna win i promise how do you figure
i just know our fans and i have i have a
feeling that very few of our fans
this is gonna bother me now why don't
you why don't we take it and put it over
there because it's doing the lift take
it and put it over there all right let's
oh i'm going to try to i'm going to try
to grow i'm going to try to live with it
morning versus you can't imagine many of
our fans are going to be saying i i
don't like staying up late versus i can
make an argument for you we got a heavy
pot smoking fan base
wake and bake you ever hear of it yeah
but come on i mean which all i'm saying
is this
i am a nighttime guy i'm an i'm what do
they call that guy night owl yeah i'm a
night owl i always have been i like to
stay up late i like the feeling when i'm
up late and i think the rest of the
world is asleep my mind goes really at
peace it's like almost like on a sunday
when i know no one's working and no
one's coming to me for answers and
everybody's taking a collective time out
that's when i have my most clarity so at
night for me is when my ideas come out
it's when i relax the most it's when the
freaks come out it's when the freaks
come out i just
taking away all the other things at
night like oh i used to like nightlife
or i used to like late night tv or you
know i used to just whatever a company's
night just not having to wake up not
associating with crack of dawn bright
and early cock-a-doodle-doo
uh night you know it's social uh or it
could be very isolating right i like all
the aspects that night works i just like
the the the what night in first i like i
i like batman and i like things that
happen at night and i like
the city buzzing at night and i like the
moonlight i like batman you know what i
mean but you know you know you don't
think a batman you think of like
brooding dark city nighttime thing in
the sky him jumping off building peering
through like the shadows like there's
just something about night to me that
rings deep where it's just like i don't
know i feel like especially being a new
yorker
anything can happen at night and
anything get like i just feel like
knight is a really
good time and for me i've always been
late to uh late to bed late to rise
uh like i said i have a clear head at
night it's when i if i'm gonna write
it's when i write it's when i need to
focus it's when i focus the most
i just like it i like anticipating
getting tired i like getting into bed i
love getting into bed i love putting on
a pair of comfy pants i love the
anticipation of sleep out of my mattress
and my pillow and and falling asleep and
being at the forefront of sleep i do not
like an alarm clock i do not like waking
up with the crack of dawn i do not like
waking up and you gotta hit the ground
running nine to five rat race i can
appreciate
wait wait no no no i'm gonna i'm gonna
call foul on that you can't you can't
put nine to five in rat race into
morning that's not fair that's an all
day how do you figure it out because
that's all day that's not we're not
talking about days nine stands for nine
anti-meridian yeah i know so you can see
the morning 9 a.m to 11 a.m counts as
morning but you can't say nine to five
getting up for your nine years
okay the act of having uh but also then
i could say getting home from your
nine-to-five job say it but you know
look here's the thing when we're in the
battle say it we're in the battle
without the ch we're in the battle
without the chant today and it's fine
it's okay don't worry about it doesn't
have to always happen maybe it's good
that it doesn't happen sometimes
but
i think you guys should define when when
the morning starts isn't it midnight
because i feel like half the things you
said is applies i think we're talking
about morning i think we're talking
traditional
late before bed when it's dark and early
waking up when it's not my takeaway tell
me if you agree morning i'd say six to
11
night i would say like maybe
nine to three
but i also want to say 10 to 12 i also
want to say we're not counting in like
and that's so 6 to 11 fine right but as
far as morning is concerned i'm not
saying
that means the way we define this is i
love to get up at six a.m it's just
because
talk to me i'm talking to you say it
tell me that doesn't include nothing
makes me feel making any assumptions
nothing you tell me nothing makes me
feel more accomplished
and more fulfilled in a day than getting
up when the sun is bright and shining
feeling energized why if the sun is
shining well so what but that's also a
a night where the weather is [ __ ] is
sucks tonight is night night is night
dark is dying i disagree
gray you could have rain you could have
i think a gray i think a gray morning is
beautiful hate a great morning i love a
rainy morning so my point is this when
you get up when you get up before at a
decent like a rainy morning yeah i also
like a sunny morning i like morning
here's why when you get up at a decent
hour
and you get
and you're well rested why because you
didn't do night guy stuff you didn't
stay up till all hours you got a good
night's sleep pineville has a good bit
about yeah you got a good night's sleep
but you get up at a decent hour and i
look up and it says 10 45 on the clock
and i'm like holy crap i've gotten so
much done today already
that i might have earned an afternoon
nap that is an amazing feeling to me nap
you mean the thing you do at night i do
with both i'll do it in both i love an
afternoon nap and i love i love a decent
bedtime i'm not gonna lie to you now
don't get me wrong we all know i have my
knights oh you're like cinderella that
become my morning yeah you do but you
you really toe that line
yeah you pull all nighters and then half
and then the other half of the time
you're like at 7 p.m i have to get going
yeah yeah
yeah i like
i like
josh slavik says if you're not a morning
person you're over with
you might be right
uh anyway i
i love
i love a barn burner night i i do i'm
not saying i don't
but i'm telling you something
morning time
if you want to feel like a whole person
if you want to feel like a complete
person if you want to feel like you're
getting something done with your day if
you don't want to feel like a bum
nothing makes you feel worse than being
in your 40s and sleeping till 12 p.m you
feel like a loser when you do that even
if you had a big night before wait a
minute you feel terrible why are you
attributing morning versus evening to me
saying that i'm waking up at noon
there's nothing to do with the other
because i'm talking about what do you
anticipate in the evening
ding ding the work bell sounds and you
get to go home you're released you're
free again you're looking forward to
dinner maybe maybe a little you know
what i mean you you why i don't know
what i like getting home putting on
comfy clothes maybe watching the evening
news maybe watching some late night tv
maybe i like to go to a movie when i go
to a movies i like to go to movies at
night i love it not in the afternoon i
love a morning movie a morning movie
i'll do a morning movie sociopath i'll
do a morning movie i'll do an 11 a at a
10 45 or 11 a.m screening sometimes solo
and i love every minute of it i love it
i prefer you step out of that theater
it's the day's just getting started are
you kidding me dude it's amazing
i love breakfast foods especially cereal
but that's guess what i can eat cereal
at night and guess what i do and i
always have that's right i'll continue
to i'll continue to eat seriously i'm
not a big fan of breakfast foods they're
one of the things i like about morning
is it it helps me look forward to my
first real meal of the day which is
lunch which is my favorite meal i love
lunch okay
uh i also love
coffee in the morning far more than i
love
booze at night
i love the feeling of getting that fresh
coffee there's nothing like waking up to
the smell of the coffee brewing that's a
nice that's one of the nice elements of
mourning that's true beautiful i don't
care where you are if you're in the city
and you live in a building all the
honking and the yelling and the
screaming begins your alarm clock goes
off you got to jump in the shower you
got to get to work if it's the weekend
people sleep in and they see that as a
benefit why because they don't want to
wake up early in the morning why because
it's just no because they don't want it
to work all day they whether they have a
day off but the morning times work if
you live on a farm now that rooster goes
off at 5am you're out there and
but
people but here's the thing people
equate the weekend with time off plenty
of people on the weekends look forward
to getting up early and having a packed
day of things they want to do versus
having to spend that day going to work i
understand in the morning yeah there's
an awesome day ahead of you but also in
the night you have the whole day behind
you do you understand what i'm saying
well sometimes for me
i wake up and all of a sudden it's like
okay he has everything you need to do
here's all the emails you have to answer
here's all the texts he has everything
you need to get done today here's all
your obligations go how about this for
the most part how about reflection about
reflection versus anticipation
reflection in that end of the day the
whole day's behind you if it was a bad
day if it was a terrible day you're not
letting it go you're bringing it home
with you you're still thinking about it
yeah guess what i'm thinking about it
when i wake up in the morning no you
wake up the next day it's it's a new day
i can god knows what'll happen let's
hope for a good day every day was a new
day i wish yeah well but here's the
other thing i'll say
people are always so self-righteous like
i'm sorry i have chronic fatigue
god
yeah sometimes yeah i don't think that
that's true morning people who is so
self-righteous in the morning who goes
you're not awake you're not doing i
could see people thinking like morning
people are the people that go jogging
that's annoying that annoys the [ __ ] out
of me look pimping i'm not saying i want
to get up at 6 a.m to go exercise i'm
saying i like getting up and doing
things around the house
people they're in your boat they're in
my boat fine but i see plenty of people
jogging at one a.m on a friday night
like psycho no listen to it
no doubt plenty no doubt people in the
morning camp there's plenty of people in
the evening camp there's plenty of them
and they like it for different reasons
if i was the guy that i wanted to get up
and do a 5k at six to 640 or whatever
the hell that is i would love the
morning but just i don't want to do the
army 5k right either the army
the
trumpet blares and those guys jump out
they jump out of bed and the drill
sergeant walks in he's like let's go and
they're sh
they just woke up a half a second ago
and they're scrambling to put on their
boots and stuff
the worst examples of mourning though
that's the worst version of a morning
sure but by the way people in the
military
tend to like that because we get more
done in a day than you do before nine
o'clock don't get me wrong too i
understand i'm not anti like i get for
as much as you can it's the lazy
breakfast and betty with the robes slips
i get it he's falling asleep with a
sandwich is right falling asleep i got a
sandwich drunk at night i get it too
yeah okay but my point is this one you
could say
you could say i'm not the rock [ __ ]
mornings that's very funny uh from the
phones you could say
you could say that for for every
everything you say a negative about like
oh if you're in the city and the car
horns and this that in the morning if
you're not in the city the birds
chirping is there anything more lovely
is there anything nicer than waking i
want to kill those birds at night when
they start chirping at two in the
morning i'm talking i want to kill them
i'm talking about the morning chirping
of birds is there anything nicer than
the pitter-patter of rain on the window
in the morning on a sunday morning you
wake up you put on a pot of coffee you
turn on a a a a lazy record maybe an
acoustic back i like an acoustic back on
a sunday morning
sometimes i like a t-rex with a nina
simone but it's your choice i don't want
to hit peta powder rain on any day oh
dude i love i love a rainy sunday when
you have nothing to do and you get up
early and you hit the ground running
with like the the video games and
pajamas or the dude
i like that you are like you hit the
ground running i'm saying if you're lazy
yeah yeah no say for a lazy day no i
know when you pack your lazy day and the
deliveries coming in and everything also
dude you just talk
huh
i i said that's that was a food delivery
a fresh take oh i thought you was just
like you're anticipating your amazon
delivery no no i'm saying like you're
the food delivery i'm saying a nice
typical lazy day you're ordering
delivery food you don't get out of the
sweats whatever but dude last week i
take that right into the eve last week
we just did christmas versus birthdays
your precious christmas wouldn't be jack
[ __ ] without the morning time oh you're
going there without a baby i celebrate i
celebrate on
midnight on christmas eve actually you
that's that's a child that was the
morning but ever since i mean the last
forty
thirty something years saying i get that
christmas eve is a fun night and
everything but you're you know it's a
great night it's the pre-eminent night
of the year for me morning is what it's
all about stuff just this morning i
actually don't love and also too if i
had kids i would anybody that's going to
have fam anybody that's going to have a
family or has a family
in morning is your time
the stories that you'll tell on your
deathbed all happened at night
morning wood versus evening woods thank
you ariel
that's a great point
that's a great point i do agree with
that i'm always hornier in the morning
than i am at night
that's gene that's but that's that's
biological so i like it that's a bonus
yeah no that sounds crazy at night time
is the right time morning wood is an
expression
that's only because your body
is
okay produces that night time is the
right time night time is for the central
people morning wood nice morning bone as
my
as my friend
greg wilson said once
uh sex in the morning is great because
then the rest of the day is just cream
cheese
is just cream cheese a thing because
that's that's a quote from um
uh teen wolf the uh oh uh yes yes you're
right
it is actually yeah
never play cards with yeah saying that
you're a shadow yeah never get a tattoo
of a dagger on your arm and never
best part of mornings is when you wake
up and you're already at the bar joe
oh that's so funny yeah it's
painful there's a quote
from teen wolf just put in teen wolf
um
uh famous
would you put no coach just teen wolf
coach scene
everybody knows what the clearing is
right here it goes right to it this is a
magnificent scene because
coach bobby finstock i parked this i
point this out every time i see this
or every time i talk about this the guy
has a fresh bucket of kfc on his desk
that he is actively eating as he's
chewing gum
[Laughter]
no way yeah and he's shaving is that on
purpose of course it's just brilliant i
never i never noticed it yeah look at
this dude he's actively chewing gum he's
got kfc open on his desk
but he eats the chicken
taste buddies it's a new year and we're
all getting back into the swing of
things we all have resolutions we all
have things you want to try and do we
got things to go we got places to people
to see and all that stuff my time is
limited i'm back on the road now and i'm
back full-time in production i don't
have the time to necessarily cook every
single night
never mind go shopping
but i don't have to meal plan or prep
now that we have something called factor
leave your meals to factor factor makes
it easy to eat clean 24 7 with fresh
never frozen prepared meals that are so
delicious you wouldn't believe they're
actually good for you they save time
uh by delivering chef crafted meals to
your doorstep eliminating the hassle of
shopping or prepping not to mention
there are no dishes to clean each
factory meal arrives pre-prepared and
ready to eat in two minutes that's
faster than evening or even ordering
delivery uh it tackles tough stuff so we
don't have to they are registered
dietitians and expert chefs work hand in
hand to create the meals that you'll be
eating with all nutritious ingredients
there's more than 27 meal options a week
so you won't get bored of the same foods
they'll even know your preferences they
have vegan
preferences veggie meals cold press
juices smoothies energy bites
plant-based bars extra protein stuff
sides and more to keep you fueled all
day long
head to
go
dot factor 75
slash plans i'm going to repeat that on
my own one more time because it's a
mouthful but it's going to get you where
you need to go you want to go to head on
over to go.factor75.com
slash plans that's geo dot factor 75 the
numbers seven and five dot com slash
plans
and that will take you to the landing
page to pick a plan and then you're
gonna use the code taste buds one two
zero taste buds 120 to get 120
off your first five weeks of meals
that's code taste buds 120 you're gonna
go to go.factor75.com
slash plans as in meal plans for a
hundred and twenty dollars off when you
use the code taste buds 120. taste buds
let's talk about warby parker if you
haven't heard of warby parker by the way
you've been living under a rock when
they dropped i was so excited because i
get really
cool stylish premium glasses at such a
low price point and all the lenses i'm
just reading i'm not even reading
anything the lenses are all uh that
reflective coated lenses which you
usually have to pay more for warby
parker was founded with a rebellious
spirit and a lofty goal to create
boutique quality eyewear at a
revolutionary price point well i just
said that in my own words offering
eyeglasses sunglasses contact lenses and
eye exams i didn't know they had contact
lenses that's cool warby parker is
committed to providing exceptional
vision care online and in stores
uh
[Music]
yeah glasses start at 95 bucks including
prescription lenses again sunglasses
progressives blue light lenses also
available so they have this thing where
you try on it's called the try on
program and this is cool because i've
been to the brick and mortar warby
parkers but i've also done this tryon
program and this is how cool it is go
online and you check out all the glasses
they have to offer it's free so the
uh program is you order five pairs of
glasses that you think you might like
that you want to try at home for free
you get them for five days zero
obligation to buy it ships free and
includes the prepaid shipping label to
return back to them so just think about
that go on even if you don't you don't
have to buy anything so you can go on
and be like oh i wonder if this would
look good on me i wonder if that would
look good on me oh is it am i bold
enough to try this style if you are bold
enough to try styles like if you are
bold enough to try styles like mike
i'm looking at him right now he he goes
bold and he only knows bold sometimes
and sometimes you know when i'm in in
the store i don't want to try like i'm
trying to glass like i'm gonna go out of
my comfort zone and then like i'm
looking in the mirror and i see people
looking at me like no honey you know
what i mean i get embarrassed i don't
have the confidence of trying any pair
in the store but anyway it's really cool
because you could get so then you choose
five they send five to the house you
have five days to walk around the house
with a pretend you're a new you you
don't pay for shipping either way and
you don't have to buy so you try five
pairs of glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com taste buds i ended up
buying the felix and i turned them into
sunglasses i got like this smoked gray
felix and then i got the what are they
called the tortoise
glasses i got a tortoise in the purse
sea glasses i love the the program yeah
that's him right there that's it yep got
him um try warby parker's free home
tryon program order five pairs of
glasses to try at home for free for five
days with no obligation to buy ships
free and includes a prepaid return
shipping label uh i believe this is only
offered in the united states try five
pairs of glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com
tastebuds
when i did i did a
i did a um uh web series called you let
me down for um comedy central we only
did like three or four episodes
but it was me giving these like advice
rants from a desk
and when the set designers were like
what do you want it to look like i
showed them that scene and i go make it
look like this make it look like the
saddest guidance counselor and we had a
bucket of chicken on the desk because of
bobby's stock but that's why i was like
that that desk is the ultimate like guy
you should not be getting advice from
coach shout out bobby finstock if you if
you're watching and we know that you are
yeah pimpy where are we out of the
clocks babe approaching 40 minutes okay
let's go to the phones we had a nice we
i think we battled it out pretty good
here
yeah i'm missing really mixing it up
i'm not gonna say that i'm gonna
instigate but i am
i i want you to challenge me a little
more i think that uh i clearly beat you
in that episode i haven't seen you in a
month
and i'm happy to see you yeah i just
think that like you also just gave me a
present yeah that's true it does which
well we didn't say no matter what
happens i love you i know we didn't i
thought that would stoke a little
something i i felt like we that was a
good debate i felt like
it was a nice debate but i really think
that i gave more than you gave i
disagree okay i think you made an
idiotic soft argument okay that didn't
really have much of the weight that mine
had if i had to listen to this debate i
would say that mornings took this by a
long shot think of the skyline of any
major city well i'll take new york front
sure when's it more magical
at night okay think of living in the
country when's it more magical in the
day except arguably stars because at
night yeah have you ever been when's the
last time you were in the real suburbs
at night like the real suburbs i don't
mean this
i mean the suburbs like out in jersey
more remote parts of jersey pennsylvania
you walk outside you can't see your hand
in front of your face dude it's
horrifying okay it's not where you want
to be at night my parents live in a
55-plus community they get nervous when
i take a walk at night by myself
that's how dark it is
i mean look
when do you when when do you when do you
like to like turn up the music music is
something that we all love right i love
morning music oh no you you you're
cosplaying in the morning music was
playing man
driving to work in the morning and they
have their
radio at like it's like
thumping i don't understand those people
like it gets me going in a door in the
morning it gets me up it keeps me moving
you know what i do with my music nice
showers nice but so is an evening shower
right before bed you know what i do with
my evening shower before bed with fresh
sheets yeah oh yeah but once in a while
maybe you know what i do with my music
at night the whole time is this too loud
is this too is this too loud i'm
neighbors this is too loud neighbors
neighbors this is too loud you don't
care if you got your music up it's too
loud at all you have a gathering you
have a party it happens at night you
have people over for dinner the most
the daytime summer bar crawl what's
better what's better what's more day
time or morning all right fine what's
more fun then when you get when you set
that alarm here's a great 6 a.m alarm
when you sit there alone for 6 a.m there
is no great exam alone i'll tell you
i'll tell you that a great 6 a.m alarm
you hit it for 6 a.m and you go right to
the bar for saint patty's day opening
and you start drinking screwdrivers
oh my god that is a bad argument a blast
you're taking saint patty's day morning
i should do it in college all the time
sometimes on halloween sometimes it's
good
morning sometimes
all i get to go is the alarm goes over
like oh my god i gotta get to the
airport oh my god i gotta get to work oh
my god i have to
i have to quickly get up getting get i
get into the shower like a zombie
sometimes there's times i don't wake up
for like an hour up till 4am bud no i'm
not getting a good night's sleep when
you go to bed at midnight every night
with the hopes of getting up at eight
a.m i try to get eight hours sleep i
trickle till about nice no matter what
though i'm i'm genetically i'm wise that
you're lying i swear to god i go to bed
i haven't received a text free in the
last two weeks that wasn't pre 1am i
haven't
you texted me last night i don't know
but i responded to what i am recording
today last night at 1 30 in the morning
i text you at 11 i said i feel like i'm
texting too late i'm sorry most of most
of my days swear swears or most of my
days i'm in bed by 12. i don't say i
don't say going to bed by 12. i'm in bed
and i'll i'll fall asleep by one so the
other beauty of mourning is the whole
it's all in front of you
everything anything is possible for that
day it's a new day you can start the new
regiment that day you can start the new
resolution what am i going to eat today
let me let me not sure but you pick it
up on any handle i could start at the
regiment that morning at night i reflect
on my day and be like look at all i
accomplished it was a horrible day if
i'm going through this [ __ ] i'm like
thank god that day's behind me sure
there's a satisfaction in what you
accomplished but again anticipation to
me far outweighs i look
i look i look more i look more i i i
look more forward to dinner than
breakfast i think i look more forward to
dinner than breakfast too but my
favorite meal of the day is lunch and i
look for i get to have lunch as my first
meal television programmer in the
morning
the worst what are you talking about
outside of regional saturday morning
cartoons as a kid nothing beat it yeah
but that's saturday morning only one and
that was as a kid nothing right now you
turn it on it's all morning shows
[ __ ] news weather
where you're still
uh emboldened to your cable in the
morning dude everybody is streaming i
watch whatever i want in the morning i'm
i'm flicking on seinfeld traditionally
this is only the last four or five years
i'm watching new episodes of curb in the
morning because i didn't feel like
waiting to up to see it the night before
i'm talking about traditional television
programming it's better at night got
that eight to ten o'clock window some
would argue that you must see tv people
would live and die
their entire lives for the ellen show i
mean who knows if i'm having a gathering
when am i having it
depends right do you ever breakfast get
together it's a wonderful thing yeah
it's a wonderful thing all right i do
want to hop in on joe's team i think
you're more anxious about what you're
going to do in the morning at night
right in the morning
i'm not
at night is when i've just left it will
prov it will deprive me of sleep what i
have to do the next i'm like adina
menzel at night it will deprive me in
the next of sleep sometimes all right
here we go to the phones mornings are
for overachievers and walk of shamers
fair point oh the walk of shame only
happens in the morning
yeah but
it's worse than that what's worse but
it's also all it is is a terrible memory
of the night before i mean it's it's
they go hand in hand the night before is
there's no shame going on night people
are straight annoying anyone who
functions better in the dark is absurd
give me a good morning when all annoying
people are asleep i agree with that
there's less noise in the morning
meaning people aren't screaming drunk in
front of bars i agree
evening all the way you can drink in the
evening and not waste the day away one
above it the one above it it's it's
wrong but it's funny so sal is a morning
person he has hope in life and enjoys
new days joe is an evening person up all
night eating too many cold cuts and
drinking to mask the anxiety he has
knowing q is going to take his spot on
the podcast
hey bud say you
that's funny that's a real [ __ ] thing
whoever chose morning can take a walk
evenings are so much better evening even
if you like mornings you have to admit
evening is a hundred times better
stress is what makes me a night owl i am
definitely a morning person we need a
funny one here these are good points but
we need a funny one
uh i would say
i'm one of those scumbags who chose
mornings evening
that's i can't
uh
yeah read that one iceberg
uh who the [ __ ] wakes up happy who is
happy in the morning unless you're
unless you're getting oral
they can beat it babe we've been
i don't i don't want to be too crazy you
know what it is i know so many younger
people that listen to this i don't want
to just like
evening morning people usually brag
about how early they get up
and lured it over you like they're
somehow better than you
waking up in the morning next to your
babe to watch the sunrise with a hot cup
of tea and a home-cooked breakfast about
the is about the best feeling in the
world until you actually wake up and
remember that you live alone or out of
fossilized [ __ ] lake [ __ ] morning
i'll give that the win for today would
you agree yeah occasional frogs yeah
okay follow at occasional frogs
uh all right pimp let's go to the let's
drum roll it uh at around 13 000 votes i
honestly don't know who this is going to
we're in a health-conscious society
right now people like to wake up they
like to get going exercise on we have a
lot of overachievers um and you
throughout like late night is for weed
but again we can say is this nobody
makes terrible mistakes in the morning
all right you make those at night yeah
here we go i don't no i don't know
oh my
yeah
i can't buy a win man oh my god that's
crazy i thought i might i thought
morning might lose but like that much
would you like whipped cream with the
slice of pie you're having hold on a
second what are the percentages really
they are bad pimp they are bigger margin
than last week you're rusty you've been
away no i'm not rushing you know what i
think might be happening
like honestly and i want to throw this
out there i just want to throw this out
there i'm not being a sore loser i
accept my loot as i said i don't care
i'm not i'm not i'm not dancing i'm
going to throw this out there i think
people are starting with practice to
vote
in what they think you chose that person
just said sal's a morning person i'm not
saying everybody i'm just saying i think
you own a bar
how could could how could anyone assume
i'm the evening person i'm just you're
joey
i'm just saying this is becoming uncanny
the drubbings i'm taking do you think
he's on the community app before the
show texting the fans
by the way
i think people
are i think people are getting very good
at figuring out which side sal took guys
that's why you call me on my community
app my number is 718-260-6619
it's a number that comes to my phone
it's only me to text you back uh i talk
to people all day long i can't guarantee
i talk to you but i also text everyone
all my info and information first before
posting online at
718-260-6619 throw me in your phones
you'll get one message that's automated
up front to say that you joined and then
after that it is me and only me uh thank
you pimp for that i don't text them no i
don't you don't i think that you
are absurd to think that anyone could
guess
who i would take the last few times i
have battled you and i would be curious
to know if q
how many times q lost while he was here
because q and i line up on almost
everything we've talked about we like
split them he won brutal beatings when
he did lose they were bad dogs cats i
think he lost
one of the worst i would like to know
the percentages because pimp you have
been witness to it now this has been
several drubbings in a row from cell
this seems uncanny something's up
something no
conspiracy theories first of all let's
talk about the drubbing because evening
is we don't have time 74 74.4
to 25.6 percent that's insane oh no
that's not as big of a margin as last
time
uh but
come on i but but buddy unless everybody
in the 75 percent of the audience smokes
pot stays up all night nobody's getting
up in the morning christmas had a slight
advantage over birthdays i swear to you
from when this from go from jump on this
one i truly couldn't tell you i thought
it was i thought it was very weighted
evenly buddy i agree
i agree but everybody thinks i'm a dirty
drunk right yeah babe that would mean
you can hear your warnings you see what
i'm saying
thank you god hello that's a good point
maybe i'm crazy yeah well i guess we
just got a bunch of drunks in the
audience too then we're gonna survive
unless all right we gotta go get me with
it yeah uh uh you know
just hit me with it remember our dates
comedy.com joe derosa's involved that's
why the commercial is there i still love
you baby yeah i love you too oh yeah
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be